ozuna hitting a buck 25
no homers no rbis let's see if we can
change either one of those columns in
this at bat
and a line drive to left field basic
dickerson's gonna play it on a big hop
here comes ronald around third throws
cut off
throw to the point of relay he's gonna
be safe
ball dropped
great speed by acuna the marlins
executed the relay play
perfectly wallah couldn't hang on and
ozuna does pick up his first rbi of the
year
it's one nothing atlanta in the first
got one middle middle of 98 turned on
you don't see the old cut off right
there too much to show
i gotta be honest i'm not surprised
about that so the braves score another
first inning run they've scored more of
those than any team in the big leagues
that was their 10th
adam duvall a former atlanta brave back
in his old haunts
he might have some right here a long fly
ball perfectly timed right on cue holly
that's a home run of the opposite field
for adam duvall
yeah you get duvall back to his old
stomping grounds and get a little
payback right that's what you want they
didn't want him back he says you know
what i'll go find home somewhere else
power to all fields gets a fastball away
great extension paul just jumps out to
right
if you were watching acuna you know that
was a no doubt
to the home third ronald lacuna junior
will lead off for atlanta
and a line drive headed for the right
field corner that's down for a hit
long run he'll track it into the corner
lead off three bagger ferrano lacuna his
first triple of the year
cloud that's what makes him so good 88
he
or 98 miles per hour doesn't try to do
too much it's inside it helps it
yeah he sees it right away this ball is
going down in the corner he's thinking
third the whole one picks up wash right
there
wash is telling him come on good start
to the inning
and he held the bag with the toe hold
there the marlins wanted to take a peek
to make sure that he kept the bag
ozzy all bees one ball no strikes ozzy
skies that one into the shift
right at the shortstop you don't see it
and he couldn't find it
look at chisholm back track acuna is
gonna tag
he's coming make home
a sack fly to second speed never slumps
and acuna flies around the bases and he
scores the second atlanta ride
you know guys watching this though right
here you know at the very end
you feel like that was maybe startling
marte's ball to call him off
coming in once once ronald saw chisholm
make that play he knew he had it with
the momentum going
violence appeal at third just to see if
acuna left too
soon he did not
no restrictions for noah tonight he
hasn't needed them he's been
very economical 50 strikes 26 balls
and dickerson went around he's rung up
at third base
and he'll take a left turner and head to
the dugout strikeout number 10 on a
check swing
first career double-digit game in
strikeouts of course
yeah he went he's going to throw it
again looks like
and it's whacked toward third nice play
riley from his
knees and a strike to first i'm gonna
say i know we haven't seen the power yet
that we've been hoping for but he has
been playing outstanding at third making
all the plays
right here knowing you got time get to
your feet
well that's one thing you always worry
about right with any player when you're
not going well offensively but
particularly a young
player that they're going to bring that
offensive struggle out to the field
but he hasn't done that here's anderson
he's popped out and struck out
another chance this time an easier one
for dansby he'll shovel to second
andy noah is through six innings with a
three-hitter
and a one-run lead
[Music]
so a full count pitch for the braves
leadoff man with ozzy waiting on deck
and here it is he lost him ball four
braves have him loaded with one out
great take nice at bat for sandoval and
acuna
and now there's no place to put ozzy
orbeez as bass in a world of trouble
[Music]
first pitch swing fly ball right field
pretty deep duval
back as far as he can go up against the
wall he makes the catch
jackson is gonna tag and score and they
apply the tag to the runner at second
pablo sandoval who was tagged out and
doubled up
but the run scored before the third out
was made at second base
and atlanta settles for one and now a
two-run lead
going to the eighth
[Music]
two balls in a strike bertie's running
pitch is low the throw to second right
on the money and not in time
dansby says check it bang bang play at
second what a throw from alex jackson
and atlanta might take a look at this
one
walt white says check it out immediately
man that got out quick what a throw by
jackson well it's a proverbial is there
enough there
can't tell from there where the tag was
applied i hate to say it if there's
this is the angle you're gonna need but
then you can't tell where his hand is
all right i'm going on a limb i think he
i'm saying he's out
i think they got him on the elbow before
they hand it the bag but
verdict is in he's out
never in doubt told you
[Applause]
and tom mattingly like so many in the
game
wonders why and now dom mattingly gets
thrown out for pleading his case
now he's gonna come out and get his two
cents in yeah and i don't blame him but
i mean again
this is this isn't these this isn't
their call
so you're i mean you know it's you're
taking it out on the messenger at this
stage of the game i mean
and i get it i understand it nate jones
is the second pitcher this inning for
atlanta
he'll face garrett cooper
nate jones that is into left field to
base it there's the hit the marlins
needed that's going to go to the wall
dickerson into score martay around third
and he will score garrett cooper comes
up with a
two rbi double and pulls the marlins
even here in the eighth
yeah coop getting it done once again in
the three spot in the lineup
fastball down he rips it into the left
field corner good speed on the bases
dickerson scores easily
all at second chisholm the speedster at
first cooper at third
but that's the man in the crosshairs
nate jones with two out
11 000 plus trying to see this inning
end
runners go 3-2 fly ball center but right
at
ender and that will retire the side the
braves walk
five men two of them score and the
marlins settle for a 3-3 tie
a little more pressure on the marlins
defense if ronald can put the ball in
play
the pitch fall forward skips up there
they're loaded what a stop by wallock
garcia didn't want to face acuna now
he's going to take his chances with ozzy
albees
another 2-2 home ground ball that's
cooper
flips to garcia we've got extra innings
at truest park garcia
works around it leaves the bases loaded
3-3 to the 10.
no coupe biggest hit in this ball game
for the marlins
[Music]
that's a base hit center field birdie's
going to score
martay moves up to third and the marlins
have a 4-3
lead
drives it into center field and picks up
another rbi three rbis tonight for coupe
three of the four marlins runs
andy grounds one fair inside the line
and down
off that little wall and marte is gonna
come in to score
to third goes cooper and the marlins get
a couple in the inning they lead it five
to three
it's probably surprised us all he's got
runners in scoring position but maybe
that's just where he's at
but able to get one over that third base
bag and drive in a run
keep it going
on long enough for the marlins to come
back
score an extras and rack it up it's a
marlins win
5-3 in extra innings in atlanta